michel thomas merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors peut-être
votre réaction après l'annoncé de cette
démission à ce que autour de vous il ya
des premières réactions qui se font
entendre
tag réaction mais à en juger par la rue
les îles et les incidents se poursuivent
autour du parlement entre les
manifestants et les forces de l'ordre
alors c'est une démission qui était
d'être là mais pas par la rue d'abord
parler ce qui mène le mouvement de
soulèvement
et cette démission était réclamée par
les partis d'opposition qui qualifie ce
gouvernement du gouvernement du
hezbollah est en fait c'était un
gouvernement qui t'es peut-être un peu
trop sur la coupe du hezbollah et du et
du parti gaulliste du de ceux qu'on
appelle ici le cpl de jeu blanc décide
c'est le principal reproche qu'on
faisait à ce gouvernement d'être un peu
trop sous la coupe du hezbollah donc
dans les milieux de l'opposition
que ce soit l'opposition de ruz
l'opposition sunnite et même
l'opposition chrétienne
cette démission était réclamée depuis
longtemps et au niveau de la rue la rue
réclame maintenant la formation d'un
gouvernement
un autre enfin de pain pas notre photo
d'un gouvernement qui veut dire d'un
système actuel c'est à dire mettre fin
finalement système actuel
non non il ne s'agit pas de mettre fin
au système actuel là il faut il faut
distinguer entre deux choses il faut
distinguer entre les pratiques du
pouvoir qui sont évidemment contestable
et qui se traduisent par le client et 10
impact de la crise par la corruption
ça c'est une chose les pratiques du
pouvoir et est le système politique en
place ce système politique en place
il faut que ce soit très clair on ne
peut pas de remettre en question de
remettre en cause
en quelques jours ou quelques semaines
les réalité libanaise son dernier ce
sont des réalités trop complexe
les
les coutumes et les clivages au liban
ont des racines qui remonte à très loin
dans l'histoire les néo réalité
libanaise au moral à des cercles empire
ottoman
je parle du système communautaire ce
système communautaire maintenant dans la
situation actuelle on ne peut pas le
remettre en cause
surtout dans le contexte actuel quand on
a des parties intégristes sunnites et
chiites et degré d aider mes mouvements
fondamentalistes
on ne peut pas remettre en cause ce
système communautaire
par contre les pratiques du pouvoir
c'est là qu'ils aient cessé c'est ce
volet là qu'il faut combattre la
violence
excusez mon la corruption le
clientélisme l'affairisme le laisser
faire laisser aller et je pense que
c'est et ça essentiellement le message
du président macro danse qu'il a lancé
l'idée d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale
et là aussi c'est discutable parce que
la nuit derniers temps pas une nouvelle
demande une honte nationale
parce que lorsqu'on parle du
gouvernement d'union nationale ça
revient à remettre au sein du
gouvernement
toutes les contradictions entre les
différents partis et les différentes
communautés
et ça ça inhibe une action du
gouvernement et ça paraît dix de
l'action du gouvernement
ce que la rue ce que le mouvement de
soulèvement réclame c'est un
gouvernement formé de ministres qui ne
soient pas partisan ça ne signifie pas
qu'ils sont pas engagés mais d'abord les
personnes de l'autre comme ça dans
l'absolu mais le mouvement de
soulèvement réclame la méline un
gouvernement de ministres qui ne soient
pas partisane c'est à dire qui ne soit
pas soumis aux dictats des partis ni
peuvent être proches de ses victimes
mais sans pour autant être soumis aux
dictats des partis comme c'était le cas
du gouvernement actuel ce gouvernement
actuel lorsqu'elle a été formé il a été
le présenter comme étant un gouvernement
formé de ministres non partisan et de
ministres indépendants
or il s'est avéré très rapidement
rapidement qu'une bonne partie de ces
mines de ses ministres étaient soumis au
diktat des différentes formations
politiques qui ont soutenu la formation
moment essentiellement la hezbollah le
mouvement nihiliste et le mouvement du
président de la chambre nabih l'onu et
et ses ministres
kalima un moment donné ils ont affiché
la liaison jouer cartes sur table et
aurait affiché l'allégeance à ces
formations politiques donc ce le défi
actuellement est de former un
gouvernement
deux ministres non partisan qui soit
suffisamment on vient entendre à la
communauté internationale va donc
apporter une aide directement au peuple
libanais une posture finalement pour
afficher sa méfiance envers les
dirigeants du pays
vous pensez que ça a eu un impact sur la
décision de cette démission du
gouvernement
cette posture de la communauté
internationale je ne pense pas que
c'était sable le facteur déterminant
d'abord il ya eu aujourd'hui et depuis
hier et dans la journée d'aujourd'hui il
ya eu une vive tension entre le premier
ministre le président de la chambre pour
des concerts et des considérations de
prérogatives
c'est à dire le premier ministre a
annoncé samedi qu'il allait proposer des
élections anticipées allant de puissance
d'achats à bon compte a considéré que
c'était une atteinte aux prérogatives de
la chambre parce que c'est à la chambre
a décidé s'il faut écourté le mandat de
la queue parlement ou non comme ça ça a
créé une tension entre le premier
ministre le président de la chambre et
ça a accéléré disons ça a été un
catalyseur qui a accéléré la démission
du gouvernement
mais pour en revenir à dette
internationale effectivement c'est être
est destiné à être octroyée directement
à des ong ou à des associations qui soit
crédible
ah non ça ça pose effectivement ce que
je disais tout à l'heure le problème de
la confiance confiance envers la classe
10 ans dirigeante ce ce qui implique la
nécessité de la formation d'un
gouvernement non partisan de former deux
ministres crédible et intègre et essai
c'est à ce niveau que le président bak
rond je pense est intervenu lorsqu'il
est venu à bégoux il a fait passer le
message
il a émis
l'idée d'un changement du gouvernement
justement pour modifier des pratiques du
pouvoir
donc ce qui est en cause actuellement au
liban ce n'est pas de remettre en cause
la diversité parce que le pays le liban
est un pays est une mosaïque de 18
communautés rythme est un pays fort mais
qui est basée sur la diversité
donc il s'agit pas de remettre en cause
la diversité en tant que tel et son
expression au niveau du pouvoir
il s'agit de modifier radicalement les
pratiques du pouvoir de démettre
campagne au clientélisme me michel
thomas de formation michel tout m'a
justement pour mettre fin au
clientélisme à la corruption ce qui ad
des figures dans le pays est ce qu'il ya
des groupes politiques qui pourra
incarner ce changement selon vous
seulement est assurément il ya des
formations politiques
il y avait des parties qui peuvent un
cabinet se serait ce changement de
mentalité dans les pratiques du pouvoir
il ya de nombreuses personnalités de la
société civile qui peuvent incarner ce
changement aussi dans les pratiques ce
que tu pouvoir et mêmes nouveau
règlement actuel concocté plusieurs
ministres qui pouvaient qui représentait
un peu ce changement de mentalité ce
moment heureusement ce gouvernement-là
gouvernement sortant était il faut le
reconnaître était sur la coupe son
intérêt sur la coupe de respawn là donc
il ya au sein de la société civile ou
bien au sein de certaines formations
politiques en place de nombreuses
personnalités beaucoup d'occases nains
qui peuvent incarner ce changement de
mentalité et ce changement dans les
pratiques du pouvoir
et si il faut une évolution il faut
qu'il y ait une évolution au niveau du
système politique
mais cette évolution doit faire l'objet
d'un dialogue entre toutes les
composantes de la société libanaise mais
un dialogue qui doit se faire dans une
atmosphère sereine calme dans un cadre
de paix civile et non pas dans une
situation de situations bien vieille
permanente où il ya un parti qui chacun
le temps fait des déclarations
incendiaires et qui déclare la guerre à
des pays amis rue du paon est qui
et qui portent des cours de jarry la
corrélation entre le liban et les pays
arabes ou bien même la communauté
internationale international de dialogue
national la refonte du système politique
doit faire l'objet d'un dialogue en
profondeur ce des bases rationnelles des
dans une atmosphère sereine la réalité
du liban est une réalité complexe qui
n'est pas nouvelle et qui n'est pas le
fruit de la gagne c'est une réalité qui
remonte à avant même l'empiré ottoman
donc je réponds ça au 19e siècle au
début du 19e siècle
on ne peut pas charger sa réalité comme
ça en quelques jours ou en publiant des
communiqués ou en faisant une
déclaration
ça nécessite vraiment un débat en
profondeur
michel thomas vous parlez là quelques
instants du du hezbollah est ce que
cette crise politique que vit le liban
est ce que le hezbollah peut en
bénéficier ce qu'il peut peser davantage
sur la politique du pays selon vous il
teste déjà suffisamment sur la politique
du pays
s'il peut pc le peser des teintures
davantage je pense que ce serait encore
un peu difficile parce qu'il est il est
suffisamment présent à cause justement
de dans son axe rennes lille et un mail
à l'adresse gola à un choix stratégique
à faire le problème qui reste qu'au-delà
au départ est le suivant ce que dans la
doctrine politique du hezbollah telle
qu'elle a été définie au milieu des
années 80 en 1985 il est écrit noir sur
blanc que pour les questions d'ordre
stratégique et plus précisément pour les
questions de guerre et de paix le
hezbollah est soumis à la volonté de ce
qu'ils appellent eux de ben ali et de sa
crise c'est-à-dire concrètement c'est le
guide suprême de la révolution iranienne
qui était à l'époque romane et lorsque
le hezbollah a été formé dans les années
80 et qui axe actuellement l'ayatollah
ali khamenei donc pour les questions
d'ordre stratégique
essentiellement tout ce qui se rapporte
à l'allemand du hezbollah la décision de
guerre et de paix le hezbollah semble
mais a family et ce qui est une
situation totalement absent mais
imaginez qu'en france par exemple
et avec un parti x sera soumis à la
volonté de footing par exemple ou bien
la volonté d'angela redonner moi oui
pardonnez moi mais on arrive au terme de
cette édition
je vous remercie d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes co
rédacteur en chef et directeur
responsable à l'orient-le jour merci
pour votre décryptage unis